[Applause]
many were amazed others shocked when
elisa longkong an indigenous mapuche
woman was chosen to lead chile's
constitutional convention
two years ago it would have been
unthinkable
but despite or perhaps because of an
increasingly uncontrollable land
conflict in south central chile
recognition of indigenous chileans who
make up 12 percent of this country took
center stage in the writing of the new
magna carta
the new constitution begins by stating
that chile is a social democratic
law-based employee national state
chile has always been pluri national
except no constitution before has ever
recognised the existence of indigenous
people
while there are scores of countries that
recognize the culture and language of
their indigenous nations with varying
degrees of autonomy chile's new
constitution if approved would go
further
the constitution includes the
restitution of ancestral land and what
we should see in many years through
approval of various laws is much more
land returned and distributed to
indigenous communities
[Music]
until 150 years ago the lion's share of
chile belonged to the mapuche today the
poorest sector society
but the concept of indigenous autonomy
recognition of indigenous laws and most
of all returning land that in many cases
is now occupied by non-indigenous
chilean families and industries
horrifies many they said a new one
former social development minister
alfredo moreno says it will cause more
conflict which nobody knows
what is that land because it used to
have doesn't have a meaning on time
what the land that they have 200 years
ago 100 years ago yesterday today then
it says that
that territory
they can have the their own government
they can have
the
they could be autonomous from the rest
of the nation
chile would be only the third country
after ecuador and bolivia to define
itself as pluri national
but that does not mean as some believe
that chile would be split up into 11
independent indigenous states
we have never proposed to install a
different state it must be understood
that the chilean state will not be
divided with different laws everything
must be within the framework of the same
constitution and the same state
the constitution would allow indigenous
communities to veto or profit from
investments on their land in chile's
lithium and copper rich north
or the forestry ridge south for example
as always the key is in the details
the laws to implement the new prairie
national state have not yet been written
while armed mapuche rebel groups dismiss
the whole exercise as a farce
many others are counting on a new
constitution to address historical
wrongs and in the process start an era
of peaceful coexistence and equality for
all
lucia newman al jazeera santiago chile